hier voici révélé que l'acteur et
humoriste ary abittan avait été placé en
garde à vue pour des faits supposés de
viol une information qui très vite a été
reprise dans tous les médias ary abittan
été placé en garde à vue la garde à vue
du comédien ary abittan l'acteur et
humoriste ary abittan a placé en garde à
vue contrairement à ce qui a pu être
annoncé au départ la femme à l'origine
de la plainte n'est pas sa compagne une
jeune femme de 23 ans qui l'aurait vu
samedi soir une plainte qui aurait été
déposée par une jeune fille s'agit d'une
connaissance selon le parisien hier soir
sur notre plateau alors que nous
débattions de la place de la justice
dans les médias bernard montiel est
revenu sur cette histoire on déclare en
connaîtra les habitants et ne pas croire
à ces allégations moi je peux vous dire
qu'évidemment je n'y crois pas à cette
histoire moi je le défends il s'est
insurgé coton d'éléments puisse sortir
dans la presse alors que l'acteur est
encore en garde à vue et qu'il est
présumé innocent je suis très étonné
aussi que la police donne autant de
renseignements ou de détail d'axa alors
que sait-on vraiment de cette affaire
comment démêler le vrai du faux ce soir
myriam palomba directrice déléguée chez
public était avec nous
alors vous êtes quoi exactement
directrice déléguée tout lui
comment vous emmener en poste entre une
semaine merci en tout cas d'être là
c'est vrai qu'on va revenir sur cette
affaire évidemment tout le monde en a
parlé aujourd'hui que ce soit dans la
presse écrite regardez tous les articles
de presse que ce soit dont les jt sur
les chaînes d'information c'est vrai que
tout le monde a parlé de ça et on entend
parler d'ailleurs pour la suite après
puisque harry a été libéré aujourd'hui
c'est ça
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça veut dire sous contrôle
judiciaire et ses terres parce que la
mise en examen ce que ça veut dire et
c'est pas vous allez nous expliquer dans
un instant je suis autant de voir la
compil des jdc ça derrière moi je dirais
que les délégués peuvent aller très vite
regarder et habitant été placé en garde
à vue une plainte a été déposée samedi
il a été placé en garde à vue dimanche
précisément à la suite d'une plainte
pour viol des faits qui se seraient
produits le jour même à paris le
lendemain ary abittan est interpellé
puis placé en garde à vue dans les
locaux du premier district de la police
judiciaire à l'issue de sa garde à vue
ary abittan a été présenté à un juge
d'instruction cet après-midi le
magistrat a ordonné sa mise en examen et
l'a placé sous contrôle judiciaire
alors que c'était partout
voilà et est ce que vous comprenez qu'on
en parle sur les chaînes info
c'est normal benjamin castadi oui allawi
à ma taille et demi dans les mises en
examen après je trouve que l'on parlait
maintenance attention à ce qu'on va dire
parce que encore une fois c'est
sûr mais en a décidément voilà
heureusement qu'on a il ya des éléments
et c'est vrai que ça va quand même
qu'ils savaient que vous êtes très
largement informé la presse plus que
tout ce que vous devriez être quoi
c'est gilbert délé plus que vous devriez
l'être non c'est à dire que là il ya des
c est louis l'avvocato il ya eu il ya eu
un dépôt de main courante est en fait
les autorités judiciaires le parquet ont
tout de suite dit il sont très
sensibilisés aux violences présumées
faites aux femmes tout de suite ils ont
dit c'est une affaire importante est
allé sans nom on aura tous les éléments
de sa sortie donc c'est vrai maintenant
avec derrière et avec carole aux carolos
livia juste hier vous en avait parlé
bernard montiel sur les réseaux sociaux
ça a été un massacre de rebondir alors
justement parce que les français sont
très partagés certains évidemment
prennent la défense de l'acteur et
humoriste et il n'imagine pas harry
pouvoir commettre un tel acte et
d'autres s'en sont pris à vous bernard
montiel qui ont été violemment attaqués
hier par prise de position tu la défense
ils ont dû car c'est ton ami tu
n'imagines pas commettre est là qu on
regarde ce que tu as dit après tu vas
nous en parle après parce que tu as pris
corps tant à l'échelle
de vue ses proches et jeux wii mais
c'est ça tout le monde est sous le choc
alors là franchement c'est la grosse
surprise parce qu'on le connaît très
bien et c'est toujours pareil on qu'un à
bochum nabot connaître les gens on sait
pas tout non plus dans leur intimité moi
je peux vous dire qu'évidemment je n'y
crois pas à cette histoire moi je le
défends parce que je sais donner son
avis je sais juste mon avis je sais
comment il est et quel rapport il avec
les femmes il est toujours extrêmement
correct c'est un mec archi honnête
vraiment donc je ne crois pas à cette
histoire voilà alors bernard hier dites
nous ce qui s'est passé derrière après
on va revenir sur les thèmes et des
coûts parce que ça a été a été dur on
sait les réseaux sociaux c'est
hallucinant tout ce que j'ai pu lire
c'est d'une violence incroyable jusqu'à
là encore de nouveau la décapitation
décidément on veut souvent de décapiter
mais c'est aberrant hier qu'est ce que
j'ai dit dans cette émission j'ai dit
simplement que c'est mon ami que je ne
peux pas y croire le connaissant je vois
pas où était le problème donc évidemment
il ya une partie des gens qui ont dit
bravo de soutenir votre ami parce que
c'est mon ami et qu'on peut pas y croire
maintenant on n'est pas dans l'intimité
des chambres comme j10 r et là ça a été
d'une violence extrême sais pas si vous
avez
c'est hallucinant alors çà et là c'est
pas justifiée alors on se marre d'oiry
habitants comme si c'était la victime
bernard montiel est un connard que ce
soit on poteau pas il faut avoir
conscience qu'on ne connaît pas tous les
côtés sombres d'une personne faut passer
très grave que bernard montiel dise
d'emblée on dirait qu'ils ne croient pas
la femme qui a porté plainte à la séance
bernard montiel ary abittan ne veut plus
d'enfants donc il n'a pas et n'a pas
violé belle défense bernard montiel donc
dans tpm paix on dit qu'il ne faut pas
faire le procès mais quand bernard
montiel dès qu'ils n'y croient pas et
que ary abittan n'est pas comme ça il
fait le procès de la potentielle victime
qu'à agir b mec voilà ce que c'est
l'année je m'en fous moi de tout ça vous
savez tous ces gens qui sont sous
couvert d'anonymat ça me rassure ça vous
a touché quand même oui parce que
c'était une telle violence et surtout
ceux qui n'ont pas compris ils ont même
déformé mes propos je moi je pensais à
la victime présumée c'est d'abord à
laquelle je pense évidemment si c'est
vrai ce moment c'est mon ami moi je
souhaite à tout le monde de défendre ses
amis comme ça jusqu'au bout je le
défendrai temps qu'on m'a pas prouvé le
contraire maintenant si c'est si mon
amitié et trahi par harry ce que je ne
crois pas je ne le crois pas toujours
pas c'est pas possible voilà c'est tout
ce que j'ai à dire là dessus maintenant
je pense évidemment à la présumée
victime si c'est le cas c'est horrible
ce qui s'est passé si c'est vrai que ce
que vous voulez que je vous dise
maintenant je défends toujours paris
rien n'est prouvé et si j'ai râlé un peu
fière même beaucoup c'est justement ça
les journaux qui se sont emparés et si
on en a parlé nous dans l'émission c'est
quand j'ai eu envie de rétablir une
forme de vérité ma vérité certes nous de
convaincre personne mais c'était sorti
dans voici s'était sorti partout donc je
trouve ça légitime que nous nous en
parlions dans l'émission puisque je le
connais bien que j'ai appelé des amis
autour personne n'y croyait que tout le
monde je le répète est sous le choc et
personne n'y croit toujours malgré cette
mise en examen sous contrôle je dis ça
on va revenir là dessus dans l'instant
pour trouver expliqué c'était très
choquant je l'avouer ce même si vous
trouvez que je voudrais que bernard vous
comprenez les critiques envers bernard
ou pas du tout bah oui parce que y'en a
oui et oui on a dit le comprenez les
critiques envers mena bien sûr que j'ai
quoi bomber je ne suis pas contre mais
largement non mais non c'est important
je comprends très bien ce que bernard a
voulu dire mais alors l'état actuel des
choses c'est trop tôt pour dire tout ça
malheureusement parce que tu peux pas te
laisser d'un godet ou d'autres on peut
le regretter il ya mon ami mina mis
d'accord mais c'est trop tôt pour passer
d'un côté ou de l'autre c'est tout ce
que je dis c'est ton ami tu peux dire
mon ami je peux je sais ce que j'ai dit
non non il dit n'est pas d'accord je
suis pas d'accord je veux dire on peut
discuter des faits mais je trouve que la
fidélité en amitié
non mais c'est beau ça a quelque chose
de beau c'est à dire que attention il
parle il dit pas je connais les faits il
dit je défendrai jusqu'au bout mon ami
jusqu'à ce qu'on me prouve moi se
trouvait au nez je suis pas forcément
d'accord avec lui mais ça me touche
vraiment et là l'émotion qui l'a elle me
touche vraiment et les scandales de 2